head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
to help you understand why what Elon
Musk is doing is so important I have a
tweet here from what is this Luke
radkowski I heard about that look we are
changed he tweeted what kind of
dystopian nonsense is this bullish the
Twitter fact check of the White House
got fact check on Facebook as missing
context this is what Elon Musk is fixing
the White House put out a tweet that
said seniors are getting the biggest
increase in their Social Security checks
in 10 years through President Biden's
leadership there was a flag a tag posted
on that on a tweet that said
actually this is because of Richard
Nixon and the increases due to inflation
it's automatic so the White House
deleted the Tweet Luke shared this image
and Facebook uh I should say AFP label
that as misleading posts claiming
Twitter started fact checking Biden when
you have partisan actors working on your
fact checking
this is what they do but when Twitter
fires them the legitimate fact check
resulted in the White House deleting
their tweet yep and you know I I got a
warning about this on my personal
Facebook page all I tweeted was the
photo of what happened on Twitter saying
now this is a fact check uh just being
like hey this is pretty incredible that
this happened on Twitter and now they're
warning me that my posts could be moved
lower in the news feed I mean they're
already pretty low in the news feed uh
they get very little engagement uh that
people are less likely to see them
because I shared a photo of what was
going on here again this is the fact
Checkers at War here and when you're
seeing this in our social media
landscape this actually gives me a lot
of optimism it gives me a lot of hope to
see this larger Battle of ideas finally
playing out in such an absurd way where
Facebook fact Checkers are fact checking
a Twitter fact check they're helping
Biden yeah this is the crazy thing if
Twitter was to remain the same without
Elon Musk they would not have gotten
fact checked this way they were would
not have deleted the Tweet they were
lying to the American people but on
Facebook you've got this one
organization called lead stories they've
published fake news about me more than
once and they've had to retract it
because they put these fake there was
one
I did a story uh around the 2020
election and it said something like
Republicans send slate of electors to
cast a vote for Trump they flagged it as
fake news and they said the Republicans
don't have electors they didn't win and
I said the Republicans did send a group
they called the Slate of electors the
first 30 seconds of the video was me
saying these are not the official slate
of electors being sent by Republicans
they didn't even watch the video they
fact checked it and they got my channel
demonetized and damaged by lying they
don't even do this is the this is the
game and you can see it happening right
now on Luke's on Luke's Facebook on
Luke's Twitter it happened so many times
it's infuriating to even keep up with
because there's dozens of events when
either it's CNN issuing a fake copyright
claim against me taking down my live
streaming abilities whether it's Reuters
saying that my photo from Davos and all
the private jets wasn't real even though
it was an actual photo from Davos I
could keep going on and on how reality
is just being manipulated in a way to
attack people who just try to give a
different perspective a different side
of the story if you're
anti-establishment you're going to be
dinged you're going to be punished
you're going to be downranked in the
algorithm and put in the Cyber gulags
for daring to express an opinion that
these people don't like and that's
absurd and this is an abuse of power by
these big Tech social media companies
that are really run by intelligence
agencies these people think that if
Republicans win
the Republicans will arrest their
children and murder them
now I'm sure not all of them think that
but enough of them probably working at
Facebook do and they're saying I have to
do this to save democracy fact check
false even though I know it's true it's
real for them absolutely yeah I think
that's what makes them so dangerous and
and so willing to to do this kind of
thing maybe maybe Donald Trump will
bring back the institution the mental
institutions and um but not in the you
know I don't want any negative ones I
want ones that actually help people I
don't like the idea that we send
medically ill people and you know
addicted people to prison people who are
unwell need help they need compassion
understanding so when someone comes out
and calls themselves frog self and
thinks the Republicans are taking
children and murdering them it's like
you are suffering from a delusion we're
not mad at you because of this we don't
hate you because of this but you are a
danger to yourself and to others and to
allow you to go on social media and
organize other people who are suffering
is going to it's going to hurt more than
just yourselves so what we're going to
do is it's called a 5150 a temporary
psychological hold so that we can assess
it you know I think There's real
challenges to allowing the government
the power to lock someone up like that
but there's also a balancing act of what
do you do when people are legitimately
mentally ill
and being given positions of power as
opposed to being given help so they can
get their heads straight well I think
we've we've fetishized this was
essentially mental illness in many cases
I mean like transgenderism is obviously
one of these things uh until recently
was understood to at least be indicative
of some kind of uh you know underlying I
think it's in the DSM-5 it's considered
a mental disorder right yeah I think
they distinct that from it's a distinct
from illness yeah I don't know that and
but well the point is is that uh We've
not only normalized it but we glorify it
you know we encourage that kind of
behavior in other words we encourage
mental illness yeah and were these
things actually require compassion
instead of uh instead of glorification
or you know simply just actually abusing
these people somehow no I completely
specifically we have the neurodivergent
trend you're familiar you're not
familiar with like a fancy way of saying
Autistic or something neurodivergent
means it means you're you're you're
you're suffering from a mental disorder
or mental illness so this starts I think
it starts on Tumblr where people head
starts on Tumblr yes somebody would be
diagnosed with like ADHD or Asperger's
they would say I'm neurodivergent like
meaning your brain is different okay
yeah they would say that it's not bad to
be away from like the norm yeah and like
no but here's the problem all of these
things start from a correct place of yo
we don't hate you for being Divergent
like if you're overweight I don't hate
you I want you to get healthy you know
I'd say you know cut out the carbs I did
I lost a lot of weight you know just I
want you to be healthy and happy I I
look I grew up skateboarding if you
really want to feel good go to a skate
park there's a lot of snooty people some
that skate but if you go to a skate park
and you're really bad at skating and
everyone can see that you're really bad
and then you finally land your first
trick the whole park erupts people are
screaming and cheering every time if if
you go to a skate park and there's like
pros the best of the best skateboarding
and all you can do is a humble kickflip
and you're trying for an hour and you
can't get it and then you go up the
pyramid and you do a kickflip and it's
the worst it's the ugliest in the world
but you get it everyone's gonna start
screaming and cheering and high-fiving
you because it's about you it's about
you doing well and doing better that's
how I view things when I see people who
are who are you know doing better
whatever I want to see them do well and
then I want them to mind their own
business so I can mine mine but on
social media the exact opposite happens
of what you just described because when
you're not doing well when you're afraid
someone when you're delusional when
you're paranoid when you have a mental
disorder you're then praised you're then
congratulated you're then even promoted
in the algorithm which has we have to
acknowledge the elephant in the room and
whether it's you know Twitter Instagram
Facebook Google especially Tick Tock uh
especially this instant kind of
glorification this this kind of
algorithm that has been running our
lives we have to acknowledge that it has
had an extremely net negative impact on
humanity and its Mental Health to the
point where we are reaching a point that
there's no going back from where people
are losing their minds and still somehow
deciding it to turn it into some kind of
content where they turn the selfie
camera on and still try to glorize it
somehow and that's non-stop what you see
on Instagram non-stop what you see on
Tick Tock and whether it's uh you know
adultery whether it's it's degenerate
Behavior whether it's just Behavior
that's extremely negative for the
individual all of that is glorized on
social media and we should really be
taking a step back from that and saying
hey we should really decide what is
going to be happening here with this
impact on society I think anorexia is a
really good example of of something we
all know and understand is is a bad
thing right it's a bad it's a it's a
negative behavior
um what's really interesting is to see
how anorexia was spread through
basically uh peer peer groups uh in a
thing that's called social contagion
that basically
um one girl would become anorexic
and then her friends would become
anorexic and then through social media
and group chats and things like that
other people who are outside of the
immediate friend Network would then also
become anorexic right because the idea
was to get their bodies to conform with
with some standard okay but the
difference is is that we knew that
things like anorexia were spreading
through pure Contagion
uh through social networks
but we always knew that it was a bad
thing
we always knew that anorexia was
anorexia was something to be treated not
something to be glorified and so you can
basically take this idea of social
contagion and apply it to like you know
transgenderism which I keep coming back
to or whatever like there's so many
other
things that fall under neurodivergent I
don't know uh and and as opposed to with
trans with anorexia which we acknowledge
was bad we glorify it now right like
when someone is skinny like that's kind
of synonymous with being a uh having
anorexia uh we don't do that when
someone is overweight or trans or
whatever or has some other weird thing
like ADHD we glorify these things and it
continues to spread through Nemesis and
so these are anorexia is uh is a mental
disorder I I'm assuming it's in the
DSM-5 this is the diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental disorders
fifth edition and this includes uh
gender dysphoria so the challenge that
we have I think is
you get banned for bringing this stuff
up yes you'll say something like hey
gender dysphoria is listed as a mental
disorder in the DSM-5 there was this big
push from activists to get it delisted
so that it would no longer be considered
considered a disorder
and then what happened was a bunch of
prominent activists said stop if you get
this delisted you can't get
prescriptions for it anymore it needs to
be a medically recognized Disorder so
that people can go to doctors and get
treatment for them so they were like
actually in their activism for like I
guess the
the status of of being considered normal
I suppose they didn't want to be
associated with a disorder they almost
lost their ability to get to get uh
treatment I think I keep coming back to
the radium fad uh a few decades ago
basically 100 years ago yeah more than a
few decades right okay yeah well we
started applying um radium to everything
like obviously watches and imports and
things like that but but people also
started to um it actually wasn't that
it's not as long ago as you think it was
the women yeah would who are doing the
painting on the watches would brush
their gums yes and their and their in
their faces and then what they would do
is they would smile and their teeth
would glow yeah and then their jaws
would fall off a few years later
here's a look up radio and the radio
Endocrinology here's a really good uh a
really good example for our time
uh for a while it was believed that if
you were a woman you could take a radium
suppository
and insert it into your body and it
would it would improve your female
functions oh wow and on the other hand
the radio endocrinologist was a credit
card sized uh uh device that as a man
you would tuck under your scrotum when
you went to sleep at night and the idea
was is that the radium would make you
more viral that if you had you know
problems what with with Mr pool down
there that it would help
um
and so when you go to sleep you tuck it
under there right and uh obviously all
this did was sterilize people really
similar to the stuff that we're seeing
now right in the end they're just
sterilized yeah but but the the really
interesting part of this was is that
Physicians believed in it yeah
physicists believed in it uh members of
the U.S government created entire
institutes like the national radium
Institute people used to drink Mercury
right but and here's here's a really
another really interesting aspect of it
in order to sell this stuff like how do
I get you to talk some radium under your
scrote right well I tell you that if you
want to be a real man that this is what
you have to do and so an entire industry
emerged to shape marketing to shape
basically conceptions of gender and
sexuality that made it desirable to
start taking radium suppositories or use
the radio and chronology because you
want to be a real man don't you with
like a nuclear something you know that
sounds like marketing you know they they
they they came up with a product yes
they said this is great we're going to
make tons of money off of this humans
you humans aren't well I suppose
depending on how you put it humans are
either stupid or they're not stupid for
the entirety of the planet we're
actually really smart but who knows
what's out there uh yeah dogs lick their
own butts no really quick a nuclear I
say nuclearized boners is is a great
marketing term yes it was and it was
super effective and a lot of guys went
sterile humans are not much smarter than
they were actually I think I think what
I read was humans are not smarter than
they were 40 000 years ago we just know
more we've accumulated more data created
data repositories so when uh you know a
new human is born all of that knowledge
has been collected and they can read
through it and learn it very very
quickly and then specialize in it that
means several hundred years ago they
would drink Mercury because they wanted
to cure syphilis and they didn't know
what else to do and they thought it
worked and they were dying and then we
discovered penicillin and antibiotics
and then also we started curing these a
lot of these diseases today or so so
going back then with the the radium
scrote tuck thing they are they're just
people who are like I'm gonna make money
sounds good to me they don't have the
data and then we get the data and then
we're like hey maybe you shouldn't do
that because I'm making your balls but
it was the marketing that they were
doing off of people's manhood
no I'm just right right but I mean my
point was that they used that man the
manly stuff was marketed for everything
right like eat your steak like a real
man there's that famous ad that went
viral on Twitter of the husband spanking
the wife because she bought Bad Coffee
yeah and it's like a lot of that
marketing existed no matter what the
product was so like brow beating people
based on their sexuality as a marketing
they still do
look at this no but look at the Gillette
commercial remember that one yeah don't
be a toxic man yeah well my my point
with the radium thing is is that it was
a moment where it was like well this
this is what the sign says the sign says
that this stuff is going to make you
more of a man right or more of a woman
and we just didn't know
they thought they did know that's my
point right the same way that we think
we do know now everything did they have
short-term results is that why they
thought about that it was like years
later the woman's teeth would fall out
their jaws would swell and get cancerous
and fall off I I imagine a tiny bit of
radiation is probably good for your body
no yeah it's heat well I mean depend
ionizing radiation is the sun gives us
some you're talking about it a little
bit talking about thermal radiation not
radio like ionizing radiation all right
so like your cell phone is non-ionizing
radiation I believe it uses what like
microwaves to send signals that don't
destroy your DNA ionizing radiation rips
your DNA to shreds causing your body uh
to be unable to replicate proteins and
then you die so this is electrons the
national radium Institute was founded in
1913 uh by a doctor Howard Kelly a
physician at Johns Hopkins and James S
Douglas who used to work uh for the
federal government so ionizing radiation
result of too much radiation if
radiation gets too insane then it starts
to ionize so the radius you're referring
to I think is like electron Decay when
the electrons are firing off because the
element is unstable hey don't don't be
mad at Ian he's on to something he's
trusting the science he's trusting the
medical experts and the government from
from day one and he's doing the right
thing according to you know the federal
government and the CDC and the FDA
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time